اكثر شيء مزعلني اليوم هو خروج هذا جمهور
السعودي حزينه من كاس العالم 2022 هذا
افضل جمهور في هذه البطوله حتى الان هو
افضل ااا حضور جماهيري اعتقد بين الجماهير
اللي كانت موجوده مع الجمهور الارجنتيني
والبرازيلي افضل اجواء كانت اجواء مباريات
المنتخب السعودي ولكن قدر الله وما شاء
فعل هذه كره القدم وخرج المنتخب السعودي
من كاس عالم 2022 من الدوري الاول بعد
الخساره امام المنتخب المكسيكي بهدفين
مقابل هدفعي بكل امانه وتعالى نحكي بصراحه
المنتخبات عرب اسيا غير معتاده على انه
تلعب ثلاث مباريات بفتره قصيره توب ليفل
في المستوى العالي يعني لما تلعب امام
الارجنتين تقدم اداء بدل كبير بعدين تلعب
امام بولندا وتقدم مجهود بدني اكبر بعدين
تلعب امام المكسيك وايضا تقدم مجهود بدني
كبير خصوصا امام فريق بدنيا قويه بدنيا
جاهز مثل المنتخب المكسيكي بتكون الامور
صعبه عليك وه ساب الرئيس كان بخساره
المنتخب السعودي اليوم اما الاسباب الفنيه
اللي اثرت على اداء السعوديه في هذه
المباراه اول شيء
فكره رينار كانت باشراك علي البليهي كظهير
ايسر واشراك سعود عبد الحميد كعب وسط
ارتكاز بصراحه كانت غريبه شويه ومش مفهومه
لانه بالشوط الاول المنتخب المكسيك كان
معتمد على الرفعات ظهر علي البليهي باتجاه
الاوزان ولوزانه كان يلعب العرضيات
للمهاجم الموجود اللي هو مارتن او لللاعب
القادم من الخلف رقم 17 لاعب وسط المنتخب
المكسيكي وهذا امر ربما كان في خطا كبير
من جانب المدرب الفرنسي همم ربما كانت
نافعه كما يقولون بالنسبه للمنتخب السعودي
همم اصابه علي البليهي وعوده سعود عبد
الحميد للجهه اليسرى كانت افضل بالنسبه
للمنتخب السعودي انا سعود عبد الحميد قدم
اضافه هجوميه بكره واحده فقط اعمل فيها
دور البوكس بوكس على طريقه وكانت كره
خطيره ونجح انه يتحصل على المنتخب السعودي
فيها على فاول قريب من منطقه جزاء المكسيك
ولكن ذلك ما شفنا اي ادواره هجوميه لسعود
عبد الحميد بالمقابل للجهه اليسرى الخاصره
الرخوه بالنسبه لمنتخب السعوديه في هذه
المباراه
بالشوط الثاني السعوديه دخلت يعني بحاله
من عدم التركيز التام كان في ضياع ببدايه
المباراه سيطر مكسيكيه كامله على الكره
هجمات مكسيكيه متعدده على مرمى المنتخب
السعودي جاء الهدف الاول بعد ذلك ايضا
استمرت حاله التخبط خطا ما كان له داعي
بسبب خطا سابق ايضا
بجانب لاعب المنتخب السعودي كلف السعوديه
فاول سجل اللاعب اللي هو لاعب الوسط رقم
24 لدى المنتخب المكسيك ونجحت المكسيك
بيننا تتقدم بهدفين مقابل لا شيء بعد ذلك
انتهت المباراه بكل امانه المنتخب المكسيك
كان افضل اليوم بكل المقاييس بنسبه
الاستحاضه على الكره وصلت بمرحله المباراه
لا 69% المنتخب المكسيك كان قادر يشكل
خطوره اكبر على المرمى السعودي يخلق فرص
اكبر على المرمى السعودي يسدد اكثر على
المرمى السعودي لولا محمد العويسي يمكن
المباراه كان ممكن تطلع بنتيجه كثير كبيره
السعوديه في هذه المباراه بكل امانه غياب
عبد الاله المالكي كان مؤثر جدا جدا جدا
جدا بسبب تراكم البطاقات طبعا نحنا بنعرف
هذا الحكي شراحيدي لما دخل ما قدر يغطيها
هذه الثغره علي الحسن كان ايضا مش هذاك
اللاعب المهم في وسط ملعب المنتخب السعودي
وخسر اكثر من كره في وسط الملعب وكان
المنتخب المكسيكي يروح فيها على طول على
المرمى السعودي كان في همم ضعف في وسط
ملعب منتخب السعوديه وكان المكسيك قادر
انه يسيطر على خط الوسط بشكل تام اضف الى
ذلك منتخب المكسيك كان سريع على الاجنحه
والاطراف كان اكثر خطوره مثل المحاكينا
ولكنه يفتقد ايضا للمهاجم الهداف اللي كان
ممكن انه يزيد غلت الاهداف بشكل كبير
بالشوط الثاني رجعنار لفكره مباراه
الارجنتين بعد ما صار نتيجه 2 - 0 وعتمد
على مسيره التسلل اللي كانت فعاله بان
الغد هدف على الاقل المنتخب المكسيكي في
هذه المباراه او ربما هدفين لها اذكر ولكن
بكل الاحوال
اسلوب اللعب قراءه المباراه ما كانت صحيحه
من جان برنار اللي غامر بمباراه حساسه جدا
مباراه لا تحتمل المغامره بانك تنزل بسعود
عبد الحميد كلاعب وسط وتنزل بعلي البلايكه
ظهير يسار صالح الشهري تبديل صالح الشهري
خروجه من الملعب كان متاخر جدا بكل امانه
يعني كان لازم في راس البريكان تحول
لمهاجم صريح من بدايه الشوط الثاني ونزل
لاعب بديل لفراس البريكان على الجهه
اليمنى قدر يقدم الاضافه مثل هتان بهابري
او اي لاعب اخر موجود عند المنتخب السعودي
كان ممكن ان يقدم هذه الاضافه لذلك اعتقد
انه ايرفينار هو من يتحمل مسؤوليه الخساره
اليوم بكل اسف مع كل المستويات الجيد التي
قدمها في مباراتي الارجنتين وبولندا في
اداره المباريات في قراءه الخصم اليوم ما
كان قارئ جيد للمنتخب المكسيكي واعطى
المنتخب المكسيكي همم ما كان يريد بانه حط
له على الجهه اليسرى واعتمد للمنتخب
المكسيكي على هذه الزاويه مثل حكينا
ببدايه حديثنا هاردك للمنتخب السعودي طبعا
منتخب المكسيك كان علاء اعصابه لانه كان
عم يستنى يسجل هدف ثالث لا يقدر يتفوق على
بولندا لانه كانت لحد ما سجل سالم الدوسري
هدف المباراه الوحيد للمنتخب السعودي كانت
بولندا متاهله على حساب المكسيك بفارق
بطاقات صفراء بفارق بطاقتين صفراءتين همم
للمنتخب البولندي كان حصل على خمس بطاقات
صفراء مقابل 7 على المنتخب المكسيكي
وبالتالي كانت راح تكون ثقيله جدا عن
المنتخب المكسيكي لو انعاد سيناريو
السنغال في كاس العالم الماضي لذلك
المنتخب السعودي اليوم همم قدم اللي علينا
نعم ولكن مثل ما حكينا قراءه النار
للمباراه كانت خاطئه من البدايه المنتخب
المكسيك ايضا خسرت تاهل بسبب هدف سالم
الدوسري في الدقائق الاخيره وبولندا
والارجنتين عنده من هذه المجموعه الى
الدور الثاني هاردك للجمهور السعودي هارد
لك الكره السعوديه البطوله للتاريخ بالاشك
ستذكرها الاشجار السعوديه لان شهاده الفوز
على الارجنتين ولكن الفوز لم يكن كافي مع
كل اسف همم مره اخرى نقول مبروك للجماهير
الارجنتيني مبروك لجماهير البولنديه وحظ
اوفر لجماهير المنتخب السعودي وجماهير
المنتخب المكسيكي